that is anthony de slofani scoffani is a
30 year old
veteran in his seventh year at the big
league level so with you down charlie
blackman will come up
because blackman breaks his bat
crawford's gonna charge he's gonna hurry
he's gonna throw and they got him
herman marquez the pitcher for the
rockies today here's dickerson
dickerson high drive
right center field
it
is here
and the giants lead one to nothing
dickerson's second of the year this is
the group that needs to get it going and
dickerson did here in the first fastball
right at the belt and spanks it right
out of here so belt for this third walk
of the young season and here comes evan
longoria
up the middle and it's gonna cost him a
run
here comes belt it's two nothing
three two [ __ ]
[Applause]
well placed right in the corner
to end the inning
inning number three giants two
colorado nothing and the colorado
pitcher
jeremiah marquez will lead off here
and on three pitches
marquez is gone so an infield hit for
story and it brings up charlie blackmon
high into the air for wade
and that's going to end the inning two
singles with two down but the two
runners are stranded we go to the last
of the third one out and here's alex
dickerson hits the pitch swung on and
missed went back to the breaking ball
second straight strikeout in the inning
two outs bases empty and here's brandon
belt brandon bell to wait saying the 2-2
got him again swinging a miss over the
breaking pitch and airmon marquez
strikes out this side bringing hillary
to the plate
and that is strike three call to
hilliard
good late breaking curveball hilliard
saw that identified it as high and all
of a sudden boom it just crashes back
into strike zone
two and two to dom nunez
he struck him out
runners stranded at third airman marquez
who as pitchers go is a very good hitter
strike three call
so both pitchers now with six strikeouts
apiece
rockies will pull the infield in
down two runs
and he got the swing in the midst of la
stella so her mom needs a strikeout gets
one
on one of the toughest guys at baseball
to strike out
wade with that base hit back in the
second
lamont with the second base hit of the
game
and he'll have a stand-up double
here's fuentes who singled his first
time flight out to shallow center
and he struck him out
yeah this could finally just worked
he just flat out worked him two nothing
giants runners at second and third
[Applause]
trump get out swinging
and that is going to end the inning
is just calfani walking off the mound
with his head high belt has walked and
stolen a base and scored a run and he
has struck out
that wall is gone
the first home run of the year for
brandon bell
tell you what he was quick
quick to the inside part of the plate
impressive how he stayed inside this
pitch
that's a breaking ball
right there at the belt
both elbows bent through the swing and
he finds the barrel head and just rides
it right out of here
97 pitches for hermond through five and
two thirds
there's stevenson
grounded towards third towards story
so he'll eat it up and that'll end
the giants threat jose alvarez the good
pitcher now for gabe kepler pitch
got him
[Music]
and alvarez comes in and makes a
statement in the first guy he faces so a
hat trick for
nunez
single came the other way in the third
ground towards the left side and that
will find a hole again
so topia with two hits
all right the new pitcher now for the
jazz will be tyler rogers
and now the bases are loaded all three
of these runners run well story has
excellent speed
and he's the possible tying run at first
so here's the veteran charlie blackman
up the middle
an overhand shoulder first
and that's going to end the inning
bringing longoria to the plate
base hit
here comes just
longoria feeling a lot better
he's got an rbi single his second of the
game and it's four to nothing
a little jam shot crawford's got it
and that'll end the inning
nice outing for
tyler rogers so flores stands in he'll
be pinch hitting
ow and he hit him
got his right elbow
[Applause]
it's hard to
say ah well i'd rather get hit here
bicep hurts
so so with the elbow
3-2 pitch
hit towards right center field hilliard
giving chase and he catches it with a
little extra
mustard on it
take that
bundy peralta the new pitcher now for
the giants coming in for the fourth time
this year
line drive
mauricio duvonne makes the cut
two and two to
diaz
he's struck him out
swinging with the high slider
two down that's the tenth strikeout for
giants pitching in this game so here is
trevor's story
longoria
to solano
and that's the bargain hard to sweep a
team but the giants do do
and they do it with a nice performance
out of discovany
and the offense showed up today